[Music]
von dutch was iconic for y2k fashion
trucker caps jeans jackets that was like
our uniform basically they didn't want
to run a business it was really a facade
everybody on the planet had one touch
hat it was like crack to the streets
i started hanging out with pamela
anderson and tommy lee money was rolling
in north of a building tons of girls and
block parties champagne private jet
paris jumps out of a pig the things that
you dream about doing i got to do all
these cars and homes it was such an
amazing achievement the difficulty was
one of the co-founders was charged with
first-degree murder
so you want to talk about von dutch i'm
ed boswell i created von dutch why are
you trying to deny me my [ __ ] i'm bobby
von i created von dutch original that's
not true i'm michael cassell and i
created bond dutch originals don't tell
people that you created the von dutch
clothing line tell them what really
happened in the neck
mike brought in tony soren's i was a ceo
but there are certain things that i
didn't know fashion's the easiest to
launder money we were always breaking
the rules
if you got the first productions of
unknowns they were all dickies i was
totally unaware when the money comes
people go sideways bobby mike and ed
were button heads we had fist fights in
the company it was hard to control the
only option at that point was
to get him out of the picture
i gotta just ask you the hard question
did you ever have anyone killed
you could call it the curse of van dyck
for the right money people will do
anything my door gets kicked in next i'm
hanging off the balcony
tony knew that bobby was a liability
these snakes consumed each other my
whole empire's grumbling i'm gonna lose
everything
you wanted revenge i met a colombian
girl connected with the escobar family
cops are flying in 50 guns on each of
our heads i was scared for our lives
this is first degree murder is this
where it is
get ready because in the art of war
anything goes
[Music]
you